hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting game from the last round of the
2018 candidates tournament I thought I I
wasn't going to show any more games from
the tournament but it would be it
wouldn't be fair to ding leerin as he is
the only player who went undefeated this
entire tournament
so 14 rounds against the world's
greatest players and none of them could
could beat him even even in a single
game and going into this round both both
Dingley and Sergey kurakin had a chance
to win the candidates but both of them
have to win their games especially ding
ding had to win and everyone else who
was contending for first place had to
lose their game for him even to have a
chance so yeah it was it was quite quite
a feisty battle and the position that
that you know appeared on the board
didn't really favor either of them and
neither of them wanted to draw but you
know that there wasn't really really
much to do here so let's let's see a
couple of photos here we do have a nice
close-up of ding leader in here and we
do have a nice photo of Sergey Kerrigan
you can see that he's well rested and
maybe even too well rested but ok let's
see this game so kurakin opens it would
be 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and Bishop to b5 so the rule opus a6
more fees defense
Bishop to a4 and now Knight to f6 we
have castles Bishop to e7 d3 b5 Bishop
to b3 and d6 this is all standard theory
and here White has a lot of options you
can go a 4 you can go Knight c3 you can
go h3 a lot of different ideas you can
try here if you want to if you want to
play E 4 you have to you have to know
all of these ideas but kurakin goes for
a 3 it's a it's a slightly different
idea which which kind of seems like it
allows white to play for advantage but
you know basically he has to try
something he does have the white pieces
and he would definitely like to win this
game here ding castles we have Knight to
c3 and now Bishop to g4 preparing the
entrance of this Knight too deep to d4
so Bishop to e3 now comes Knight to d4
attacking the bishop on b3 and also now
attacking the pin piece the knight on f3
basically for forcing white to give up
the bishop pair so Bishop captures some
d4e capture some d4 and now Knight to d5
and here dingos c5 capturing the knight
isn't isn't a problem for black you
could capture and after Bishop captures
rook the c8 Bishop to c6 does seem like
like a very annoying move but it's it's
all gonna be good I mean the bishop on
g4 is spinning this night and if three
nicely white will have to push h3 at
some point if he wants to play anything
at all and then like will simply go back
and after the exchange happens it's a
perfectly fine position for both white
and black so after Knight to d5 probably
if Dingle was interested in wrong maybe
maybe he would capture it but he does
have to keep his options open
so so c5 we have 84 now Bishop to e6 and
Knight captures on f6 Bishop captures on
f6 Bishop captures on e6 and F captures
on e6 and it doesn't seem that this is a
better for black than the line we just
showed but there is a lot of imbalance
to the position which which could create
some some winning chances without
worsening the position too much so Queen
to e2 may be preparing e5 in some in
some variations Queen to d7 now
preparing after a capture some b5 and
the ache after some b5 rook captures an
a8 and now this rook will be a it will
be able to recapture on a8 so b3 we have
E 5 now rook to a 2 preparing to double
up on the a file and B 4 so Claudia
decides to close the a file nice to d2
by playing this before move ding is no
longer controlling the c-4 square so now
this Knight is preparing to come to c4
White will push a 5 at some point and
then from there he will be able to jump
to b6 maybe he won't even have to maybe
he will simply stay on c4 to may be
pressured e6 a lot of ideas for this
night here
so rook 88 and now rook a to back to a 1
as there's no point in doubling rocks
and the a file now the rook will come
back
Bishop to d8 now controlling this a 5
square maybe when preparing to push a
fight himself but you know you
definitely want a bishop there even if
white pushes a 5 this rook will always
have to stay on a1 so it will it will
have to protect this point if it's ever
pushed here we have g3 with the idea of
pushing f4 and if you decided to play
something like g6 here we would most
definitely see f4 e captures rook
captures rook captures and G captures
and after.look to a fate rook to f1
which what a decent position for both
white and black
maybe maybe white because of his grip in
the center is slightly better but
nothing nothing too serious but after g3
ding played g5 and this this was a shock
to everyone why would you play a move
like this but it's actually it's
actually the most precise maybe not the
most precise but it it definitely
accomplishes what needs to be
accomplished it prevents f4 here another
thing is if if kurakin could get this
Knight from D 2 all the way to f5 this
would be this would probably be a
winning position for white the problem
is there is no way for you to actually
do it here Kirk and played Knight to c4
but if you try something like f3 for
example f3 with the idea of maybe
playing rook to have to going
Knight to f1 pushing g4 then bring your
knight the g3 and then to f5 this simply
doesn't work because black will simply
play normal developing moves and he will
stop you before we were able to execute
this rope to f2 now Queen to g7 and
after we play Knight to f1 black will
simply push h5 and now your ideas just
silly and your pieces are looking pretty
terrible of course if you push g4 you
will get h4 this will not allow your
Knights to come to the g3 will not be
able to come to e3 and you will never be
able to get that to that f5 square
so after this
after this G to remove and g5 carbon
went Knight to c4 so rock to e6 and now
a5 preparing preparing to bring this
knife to b6 if needed so this rook can
move from da file the knight and b6 will
will prevent the bishop from capturing
the a5 pawn here we have a rock to f6
now doubling up on the F file and now f3
h5 we are nice to be six and now Queen
to f7 we have a queen a queen rock a
rock Queen rock formation the F file by
ding King to g2 and now comes h4 and
this is a definitely the critical moment
in the game here whether whatever you
like it or not you have to play G
captures on h4 followed by G captures on
h4 and now bring the knight back to C
for the night will be useful there he
will pressure this d6 pawn and doesn't
matter any rope to g6 check into h1 your
your own rocks will come to the G file
and all will be well but after this h4
move carrucan missed this idea because
he missed a very nice threat biding he
played Knight to d5 with the idea of
attacking this rock on f6 and it doesn't
seem like the rook has anywhere to go
you can go you can stay on f6 you can go
to a5 you can go to a for I you'd have
to move it but moving the rook moving
the rook will only result in a better
position for white for example roof to
g6 then you capture on h4 and black
recaptures you move the King and you get
the position we discussed but deciding
to do this differently would this would
this move order kind of playing Knight
to d5
being an improvement as it forces the
work to move voluntarily or
involuntarily here feel free to pause
the pause the video and find a nice
combination that Sergei missed and the
ding found so as usual I will give it a
couple of seconds feel free you know to
enjoy this position so for those of you
who found the move congratulations and
the follow-up on the move even even even
more important you are an excellent
player and for those of you who just
so here Dean played h3 seems like weird
move of course but it's really not you
can't grab the point you have to go back
with the King and then you're you're in
trouble because not enough pieces are
defending do you have to rip on a
problem is if you capture here then you
get the immediate follow-up g4 and now
you lose the game you lose because if
you go back then simply G captures on f3
wins an entire rock you have to react to
this or you lose the Queen rook captures
rook captures and now you're down a rook
black is completely winning here another
thing after this h3 and King captures in
g4 you can't go to h4 if you play king
h4 rope to g6 opens up a discover check
from the bishop and not allowing you to
go back to h3 also the rock is not
protecting the pawn you can only block
this check once now Bishop captures and
this is checkmate
after King to h5 and the Queen to h7 and
another thing after this g4 move F you
can even capture the pawn but now you
get Queen to d7 check King moves Queen
to h7 check now and after King moves
rook to g6 and this is once again
checkmate
so this is a one trick Sergei missed and
now he's forced to go to g1 and he loses
the f3 pawn here rook captures an f3 was
played and here he did blonde or a pawn
ok but again you know he was he was
really composed and he played the g4 g4
is the strongest engine move with the
idea that you have to play it if you
decide to go rock captures on f3 Queen
captures Queen captures and the rook
captures now you have a problem you you
could try a knight to be 6 but then
after King to f7 you have to go rook to
f1 and now rook captures King captures
now a black will lock in the position by
playing G for himself and the points
here are completely blocking the White
King from entering the position and now
the black King will simply get closer
try and capture this night if the knight
moves then the king will simply come all
the way to b5 and then the best
win the pond and then black will win the
game so G for a very important move the
only move that saves the position for
white
the idea is king to g7 now rook to f3
Queen to f3 Queen captures rook captures
and now rock to f1 rook captures keen
captures and now Bishop captures an a1
so he did have to give up this a pawn
but now after playing g4 the King can
enter the position and also the King
will grab this h3 point so maybe h4 will
be an idea in the future
allowing actually White's to have some
winning chances but you never know
Knight to e7 we have King to f6 and now
Knight to f5 an excellent score for the
night and it would be great if he could
just stay there you know I think that d6
pawn but black played of course King to
e5 and well of course push d5 he won't
allow this d6 pawn to stay a target
Knight to g3 now this night has to go
back
we have Bishop to d8 and now Knight to
h1 with ideas of coming to f2 and then
guarding the epon from there we have a 5
now comes King to e2 you do have to
bring the King over to the Queen side
not to help out with the defense after
black pushes a for d5 now nice to f2 we
have King moves he captures on d5 King
chapters on d5 and now Knight to e4
again an excellent square for the knight
now it attacks the C for the the the c5
pawn and also the g5 pawn but the bishop
will have no problems guarding against
both of these threats King to c6 now the
king is coming to help out would with
the execution of a for King to d2 we
have Bishop to e7 now the bishop is
guarding both of these points that are
attacked by the night king c1 king b5
King B - and now a for what do you do
here it doesn't really matter you could
capture and after King captures goal
King a - doesn't really matter in the
game after a 4 we have King to a 2 and
here being simply pushed a 3 and it was
in this position that Sergey Cara can
ending
agreed to a draw as black is black is up
upon but there is no way there is no way
to actually push anything here there's
no way for for black to make any
progress here white can always simply
win this pawn and then it's it's really
nothing there's no way to enter the
position all of all of Karin's pawns are
are on light squares except this one but
after you capture the a troponin push h3
and there is no way for this Bishop to
ever be a useful piece all of ding
spawns around dark squares so it would
be if the engine is giving to point to
point over the Vantage to black but it
doesn't matter
there's no way to to actually win this
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and yeah once again
ding Liron is the only player who went
undefeated this entire event so 14
rounds against the world's greatest game
grandmasters and no no one was able to
defeat him and it's not like here we did
in his run in the candidates where he
drew all the games ding liver and even
won one game and I forgot to show you
the results in the previous video so
here are the results and some statistics
after 14 rounds of the 2018 candidates
tournament as we all know carbon Fabiano
Carwin won the tournament with 8 points
then we have in second place mama dro
with seven-and-a-half kurakin with seven
and a half then ding leerin with seven
alexander grisha with six and a half of
Vladimir Kramnik with six wesley so with
six and eleven aragon in last place with
four and a half points
so not the greatest of tournaments for
Lebanon I'm sure he will immediately
forget about this as in three days the
Greinke chess classic starts at work he
will again faced off against Caruana
which monitamon and Maxine Bashir and of
course magnus carlsen and a lot of other
players but you can see also how many
rating points the players have won all
the way to the right of the table
Caruana 115 rating points fifteen point
four which brings him all the way to
again entering the 2800 club
mahmoud Arif stays in the 2800 club he
even won some points Cora can also won
or about 15 points fourteen point nine
and a lot of other place people want
some points ding we were in 18.7 and the
people who lost points our chronic with
8 points he then drops out of the 2800
Club Worsley so also he lost 13 points
and 11 Iranian lost 26.6 a low points
and he is now no longer he's now no
longer even in the top 10 chess players
of the world
bye-bye live raiding but I don't think
as the month is almost over then it will
no longer be only live reigning but also
you know standard rating as the first of
the month you know the rating updates so
yeah that's the game I would like to
thank Paul Givens Paulson on Martin
Wilbur Douglas Jennings James Norwood
and Gerard ruble for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here once again I
would like to thank Nicky for for
sending us her photos from the
candidates tournament so we can enjoy
them as usual in the description below
all of the links to her social media
will be there feel free to follow her if
you enjoy some just photography and yeah
on an off topic I I picked up
hearthstone again and I've been playing
for like a week now and I managed to get
the rank 6 almost rank 5 maybe maybe
I'll get to rank 5 today so I will also
put my what's called the Blizzard handle
in the description below if you wanna if
you wanna
you know get a get together and maybe
maybe play a few games so yeah and maybe
all me maybe I'll even make a
hearthstone video or two who knows so
yeah once again thank you for watching
and I will see you soon